it's not about you can eat your cake
everyone can eat their cake
potato the whole point is like cake is
us
so i look at it in two ways so i
personally feel like that person has
taken me from one space or level in my
life to another so i'm forever grateful
and i also in the same note feel like if
i was to ever be in the space that i
could repay
in any way shape or form that i would
you know what i mean but um
and the other side of me is like you
can't take it back anyway so it doesn't
matter
because you've already placed me at this
space
so it's like yeah unless you want me to
fake be with you
to keep my [ __ ] then let's just be
friends and it didn't work and that's
that but you got to continue to you know
your credit is going to messed up i
don't know
but he continued paying that he did
continue he's yeah he's still paying it
yeah yeah are you with another dude yeah
it's been like i've been with my guy
maybe like going on one year and he's
been paying my bill i would love to meet
your guy
i would really love to meet him because
those men are rare
to stay in that house that another man
is paid in the business
my man feels like let's while we have
this opportunity let's stack our brand
so when you know when they like you then
that's why y'all together
the amount of dysfunction in this
[ __ ] video bro it's triggering
if i was with a girl and i found out her
ex was still paying the bills
[ __ ] you also my ex that's crazy
that's crazy unless it's like alimony
from my ex-husband
he's just paying the bills willy-nilly
that's us
that's us and her being like yeah like
you know
if i can do this thing to support my
that's a wheel that's weird
it is weird we don't stack our bread so
you're seeing your ex as an
opportunity to get ahead meg
that's super weird listen this is the
new wage you know where people just
i know people openly make yeah i just
throw bills at the girl you know what i
mean
the ex is paying the bills cash app yeah
i cash
out for like man this is so common yeah
and it's one of those things where it's
like what is it that you're paying for
what do you why but then that's what
that is
yeah i think he's a sucker he thinks
that
rightfully so so the man who's taking
advantage of the sukkah
is in my opinion pathetic
but the guy who's being played for a
sucker knows this and still pays a bill
is an even bigger loser
in this whole thing it's like damn i'm
out here doing her a favor and they out
here
playing on my name both
both of of them she let it slide he
thinks that but i don't think that no
that's
that's my friend that was your little
brother i feel like your little brother
that's my friend how many friends are
out here paying all your bills
you friends own him how many of your
friends are out here paying all your
bills
how many your friends are coming through
and paying your rent how many of your
friends are coming through
and setting you up in a spot and paying
for
do you know
friend no no no boo this is your mark
your mark yeah speak on that
it's like when someone gonna scheme
somebody
they get a mark yeah right they'd be
like
i could get that yeah get you to do that
make you
mine and then extract from you all the
resources i want
because you are susceptible right yeah
scam
scam artists know how to pick well
scammers sometimes do the math thing
but those who are more personal they'll
have their marks
they'll go for certain age groups
they'll go for people from certain
backgrounds
people don't have any families same
thing for like criminals like
it's the same nonsense what's the
difference between this and your friends
paying your bill
like a bill catching a bill i know you
were in the top spot whatever
let me grab that bill for you what's the
difference what do you mean like a food
bill
no not just a food bill groceries
whatever you know your friends in need
or whatever
a grocery thing is a completely
different thing if my friend is
struggling one-time grocery but i'm not
going to subsidize him for months i'm
not going to put him up an apartment
hey bro mm-hmm you need a condo there's
a difference 200 b
jeez one [ __ ] no no
no now it becomes like my friends i
could help them in a tough spot
[ __ ] i know do i look like universal
credit
no you don't do i look like welfare
neither
okay do i if you think i am [ __ ]
but yeah there is a difference let's be
honest
i have a son if my son was well off and
he decided to put a woman in a car i
would feel like that's disrespectful for
you to take you should have never put
that woman in that car
that's how i feel and i want and i
raised and i killed
and i raised that money in that car then
he should have thought of that in the
budget from day one when he initially
got the call
you know what i mean because but if
you're open about things like i was in
this relationship where it just wasn't
working but we remained friends
and he was still paying that during our
friendship and then maybe like five
months later i got with my guy
you know you're not gonna stop so this
has been going on for more than half a
year
ideally yes i've dated a guy who was
very wealthy when we separated
he was still paying the bills right
under the contingent and the
understanding that i'm not [ __ ] with
nobody else
so i hid that i was in another
relationship for a while
did i ever discuss with the other
significant other that this man was
still paying the bills
yes but you know what happened
eventually eventually he said yo if you
if you're going to be with me 100 you're
not move out of that apartment
whatever attachment you have with this
man you got to wrap that up or you're
saying to me
that you're trying to have your cake and
eat it too which is a bad analogy
because if it's my cake i can eat it
right all of it
i think you misunderstood the analogy
having my kid eat it too
it's not about you can eat your cake
everyone eat their [ __ ] cake
potato the whole point is like cake is
[Laughter]
no that's so stupid it isn't you have a
cake and if you eat it you don't have a
cake no more
i'm
if your cake is there and you eat it
your cake is no longer there
right you can't have your birthday cake
you can't have your celebration
if you ate the cake oh cause it's little
luck
i'm glad i'm glad i glad you caught that
i'm glad you caught that that's a stupid
analogy uh because
because you know it's your cake you
should eat it because it's yours you
know what i mean
like it's sure it's your cake so yeah
you should have your cake and eat it
because you know it's yours so
it's my cake i can eat it right
that's not
i feel like here
i imagine you go up to a girly like
man life is like a box of chocolate how
many girls like so you just eat it
it's like no no
you never know what you're gonna get
yeah you can't you know what you're
gonna get sprint on the box
all the flavors is there you got cherry
chocolate you got the white chocolate i
really like those
you got uh probably name then you have
uh sea salt and caramel oh i like that i
like me some caramel
and then you know exactly what you're
gonna get it's written on the box
is it written like the flavor of
but the thing about it is it's like
who's who's getting your
he still has a piece of you so now i
have to decide what kind of future i
want with this other man
is he just something to fly by night and
i'm having a good time because if that's
so
then i'm gonna have my cake and eat it
too i'm gonna keep this one paying my
bills which is
lovely and this other one doing whatever
role he plays but if i'm trying to take
it to the next level
then at some point even me moving into a
man's house and that bed is already
there before i got there we gotta get
new furniture sweetheart
it's time to get a new mattress and
everything i don't want the mattress
you've been sleeping on with the other
so [ __ ] incredibly stupid imagine if
you got your favorite bed in the world
you [ __ ] some broad then you meet the
girl of your dreams y'all get mad [ __ ]
throw out the bed you [ __ ] some
what what a waste of a bed what a waste
of a bed this is so stupid no wonder you
need somebody else to finance your
[ __ ] life
if you throwing out a whole nice bed
cause somebody else slept in a [ __ ]
[ __ ] i know you don't stay in airbnbs
that's cause i know you don't stay in
airbnbs
what you mean have you ever stayed in a
hotel do you know how many people [ __ ]
in that bed yeah it was just
it's just it's that's that's not a
rational thing that's the natural thing
stupid that it is
personal because you wouldn't go in
hotels you want to go you know what i
mean they don't change the beds in
hotels
sometimes depending on the hotels that
you go they don't even change their back
covers
no iq just press play i mean all right i
mean
i was with you not holiday yeah
the man met your beautiful mother god
bless both of them
why why does a man gotta buy a whole new
damn house
all right i'll let y'all go like let's
not over now let's
be realistic if i meet a woman that has
a beautiful condo
that her man has bought her and i walk
in there
the last thought on my mind is like oh
[ __ ] she was getting [ __ ] in here
i gotta buy a whole new condo i'm not
doing that
thanks guapo she's a thing this man's
not seeing robert science is that these
girls sound so stupid that you hear
something like
if i meet a girl i don't need her to buy
a new house you know
it's not it's not right these girls
sound so stupid
that you're like oh obviously yeah what
a breath of fresh air y'all are not
playing it if you have self-respect you
don't allow some of this stuff to happen
like this is so outside of the realm of
my
existence so i'm just like who raised
y'all
but at the end of the day some people
allow this you know it's like
people will only go as far as you allow
them most of them yeah
and the truth is a lot of people allow
all kinds of [ __ ] into their life so
there has to be some measure of
accountability on his end for getting
played like a dummy
um you know and as far as she goes like
she's delusional she's talking about
like well i invested my time
and my effort into him she's talking as
if there's some measure of respect
but then she also got a boyfriend who's
clowning the dude and looks at him like
he's pathetic
so it's all just a facade bunch of
[ __ ] and
like i said man listen if if if they're
tricking
then pay for the trick but a lot of
y'all stop need to do in these cash apps
and pretend like it's not tricking
okay if you let dudes pay your bills and
do all this stuff and they get to bang
you
you a hoe and it's okay but let's stop
this whole respectability [ __ ] like
no it's fine just be a hoe
you're using your assets which is fine
but i mean
i'm not saying that it's okay i'm saying
that
it's expected but
to me i was watching this i was just
cringing that's pretty much my whole
image anything else you want to add
no there's nothing you said what you
said yeah all right then let us know
what you guys think of the comments you
can have your cake and eat it too cause
it's yours
[Music]
is
falling for me